president Trump signed a
multibillion-dollar coronavirus relief
bill into law last night
this legislation gives many Americans
paid sick and family leave but it
reportedly leaves out millions of people
people with businesses with more than
500 employees and in some cases less
than 50 öre exempt now it's estimated
nearly one in four US workers do not
have access to paid sick leave and
nearly 60% are living paycheck to
paycheck Adriana Diaz reports from
Chicago where some hourly workers worry
they will now have to make a very
difficult choice good morning there's a
lot of uncertainty right now working
remotely simply isn't an option for
someone who flips burgers works a cash
register or drives a school bus for
people barely making ends meet as it is
it may be less willing to miss work no
matter what the reason plus they're
often interacting face to face with
customers putting them at risk of
exposure 27 year-old single mother
Adriana Alvarez has been working at this
McDonald's since she was 17 and she says
she can't afford to get sick every two
seconds hand sanitizer there's a lot of
people coming through the drive-through
were exchanging money and were
exchanging we're dealing with food what
if it spreads through food you know what
I mean McDonald's told us it's bolstered
its hygiene standards and shipped it to
takeout drive-through and deliveries in
company-owned stores and it says its
strongly encouraging franchises to do
the same the franchise were Alvarez
works made that switch this week a
leader in the fight for 15 minimum wage
movement Alvarez is calling on
McDonald's to provide paid sick leave to
all employees so you do have sick days
but it's hard to get them okay it's hard
to use them
yeah they don't they don't want to give
it to us I don't understand why the
health and well-being of our McDonald's
sent CBS News this video statement
saying corporate restaurants are
providing two weeks paid sick leave due
to the virus but that doesn't apply to
franchises we have an amazing group of
franchisees who lead almost 95% of our
restaurants
I'm confident they will support their
teams in a time of crisis we reached out
to alvarez's franchise owner but haven't
heard back for alvarez and her
seven-year-old son Manny she says every
hour of work she misses is a precious
$13.45 lost basically one paycheck is
for the rent the other one is for
groceries and then it's watching the
calendar waiting for that next paycheck
with like 2530 dollars in your bank
account
president Trump signed a coronavirus
emergency relief package that includes
paid time off but Alvarez is skeptical
help will come I'm not completely
confident now right as of right now I
would much rather go to work sick
because I can't afford to miss a day so
if you got sick you would still good
work unless I'm like I can't get up then
you will see me at work unless you
physically cannot assess yes I get 20 75
an hour how hard is it with the job to
make ends meet is very hard
Sheila read a school bus driver of 17
years is now out of work completely
after Illinois closed schools this week
she's expecting to file for unemployment
but she says won't cover all the bills
and food to support her two daughters
and two grandkids what keeps you up at
night
then worried about them I don't know
it's okay and now with this new world we
live in
everything's upside-down it is very much
upside-down and red is not alone a new
survey found that one in five households
has already lost work because of this
pandemic and school closures are further
complicating life McDonald's worker
Adriana Alvarez is now trying to sort
out childcare for her son
adrianna thank you such an anxious time
for so many people we're already seeing
a big spike in unemployment claims in
many cities around like that even some
websites at the state level were
crashing because they couldn't meet all
the demand yeah this new normal is not
fun and we keep hearing we'll get
through it we'll get through it and I
believe we will but I think people don't
know how oh how these people don't know
how long it's thinking these low-wage
workers are some of the highest risk
because they're dealing with people
every day they're working at Starbucks
there were supermarkets exactly exactly